get a fans idea what it's like to
playing a spectrum at home you know when
you watch him you see the arms handling
you see the crazy left-hand throws when
he's falling you see all that you see
the ability I think the one thing that
people don't talk about enough is just
this competitive nature like that dude
is one of the most competitive people
I've ever played against you know when
I'm out there he's talking right back at
me and most quarterbacks aren't like
that you know they're silent they're not
going to say much Pat's one of those
guys that he's going to get right back
in your face and be like yo like let's
go then what's up we were playing in KC
and uh the environment was crazy it was
Monday Night Football I got him with a
sack on the first drive and ended up
getting him a second time and I'm
talking Pat wasn't going for it you know
he was talking bad and so they went down
and scored and they were all running
around the end zone I get bumped behind
my back I get hit with his shoulder I
turn and it was Pat and he was still
running and I'm like oh no I'm not going
for that so I ran straight to him and I
head butted him like what's up so we
were just John and you know everybody
online obviously made a big deal of it
after every single time we play he's the
first guy that comes up to me and we
always show love